[Music]
there goes the Baker with his tray the
same on bread and monster Sun every
morning justices since the warning that
we came calling Bell opening Monsieur
Jean how do you got something again I
believe I have problem is I can't
remember what well I'm sure it'll come
to me
where are you off to through town
inspect peril bear it's about two lovers
in fair Verona sounds boring
[Music]
he's a distracted conscience he'll get a
stop and eat well it was a heads up on
some ground in the denied she's a funny
My dear Belle your soul ahead of your
time this is a small village you are the
worst gorgeous thing I've ever seen
nobody deserves and if small minded as
well but small also means safe
please come to my father he's a thief
Cullens the light
look a girl who said that ello but you
can talk hello pause it's all he ever
does
how lovely tonight your acquaintance
why don't you do a trick what happens
from the last petal for the mass tell me
immense a beast forever and we become
antiques
what is he doing get out of here
you have to help me you have to stand if
she is the one will break the spell you
must finally learn to love have you
really read every one of these books
some of them are in Greek
[Music]
sweetener
rising in
me
I have loved beating Abby since I was
about four years old I know that I've
seen it hundreds of times since and now
that I have kids my own probably
thousands I just thought it was the most
beautiful and perfect movie question
becomes why remake something was perfect
part of it was this great opportunity to
tell it end a live action fully photo
real version and distinguish fell again
25 years later as a 21st century parable
when you love something that much you
really want to do it justice it was
something that we all knew we had to
live up to who's that who names the
night we have this extraordinary team
who are legendary they have given us hug
means that we needed to make it
everything it could be hello you can
talk it feels really good to be in this
group of actors is an amazing cast
there's so many wonderful iconic roles
in
it was enormously exciting to see so
many people concentrated on creating
magic that will enjoy pleased to meet
you worked on films before where the
craftsmanship has been amazing but this
has been unbelievable
show me the girl the music is pretty
special what if she is the one who break
the spell
we saw meet are very powerful they
arouse emotion carry you along think of
the one things you've always wanted
there's something about this story and
the score that draws everybody in I find
it your mind's eye and feel it in your
heart it will remind you of all the
beauty of the original but also expand
on it and give it more detail and more
depth this version of Beauty and the
Beast will define a whole new generation
in a wonderful way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh yeah you must leave here disgust is
alive who's there
do you wish to take your father's place
Collins the light
show me the girl look at her what if she
is the one the one will break the spell
hello
you can talk well of course he couldn't
talk hello
pleased to meet you the Masters not as
terrible as he appears
shall we kill the bee
think for one things you've always
wanted
funded your mind's eye and painting
Wow
don't be afraid
'my friend
[Music]
look [ __ ] sloth a beautiful girl piecing
the Beast really characterized a huge
part of my childhood of my growing up
the original is bluff but with the
current technology and craftsmanship is
there was so much more to explore
Galloway
you can talk the opportunity to bring it
to life was very exciting we have
someone for you to throw this we're so
blessed to have artists like Jacqueline
Duran who's the costume designer Bell's
costumes are based in the animation so
her village dress is an homage to the
blue dress a big part of creating Belle
was working with Jack Angela bar loves
to read so he created these pockets to
the velvet always carry the book she
loves rides it has one side of Husker
hitched so that she can get a leg over
horse we wanted to feel beautiful but
also this is something that's part of
her
with the yellow dress we went through a
long design process I can think of very
few dresses that are as iconic as that
yellow dress what we decided was it had
to dance beautifully it was a very soft
structure which was built up with meters
and meters of silk organza cut broadly
in a circular shape so that it
emphasized her me.we prints and gold
leaf onto the dress and Swarovski
crystals is just gorgeous to the fair we
wanted the dress to feel like it could
float and it does it just is perfect for
that moment now coming final checks
everyone they've taken something which
is so well known and expanded on it and
give it more depth they've just done an
incredible job I once a dancer and the
great white somewhere hello I wanted
more than I can turn into the light or
once it might be around she is the one
you had fun I'm just a face to meet you
I want
Disney's Beauty and the Beast rated PG
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
look a girl yes I can see it's a girl
food what if she is the one hello
[Music]
I want adventure and the great white
somewhere hello I wanted more than I can
turn come into the light for once it
might be clear out she is the one you
have someone I'm just a face to meet you
I want so much more than Disney's Beauty
and the Beast
[Music]
hello look a girl who said